2025年，当谷歌的James Rui登顶AI性能排行榜的时候，
训练他的不是英伟达的GPU而是谷歌自己的芯片，TPU。
从搜索翻译到地图，甚至是Alpha Fold 2，
TPU它驱动了谷歌几乎所有的核心产品，而如今它正在向整个的AI产业摄像头。
2024年，苹果发表论文，Apple Intelligence全部使用TPU训练。
2025年，Anthorropic拿下100万颗TPU，价值数百亿美元，用来训练下一代的Cloud。
2026年刚开年，Nata就签下了数十亿美元的协议，租TPU来跑Lama。
过去我们说整个市场都认为，未来AI芯片的机会在于推理芯片，
因为达在训练芯片的地位是难以撼动的。
但是我们看到现在在越来越多的顶级模型公司中，
谷歌的TPU正在成为英伟达的替代方案。
你觉得现在谷歌的TPU可以挑战英伟达在GPU的垄断地位吗？
在某些限定的条件下，TPU是完全可以挑战GPU的。
很多人都在讨论TPU和GPU之间区别，我熟悠熟练。
未来肯定是两者并存的。
哈喽，大家好，欢迎收看硅谷101，我是红军。
今天我们来聊一聊谷歌的秘密武器TPU。
今天跟我在一起的是谷歌前TPU的工程师Henry。
哈喽，Henry，你好。
哈喽，红军，你好。
首先给大家做介绍一下。
我的名字叫Henry。
很开心，硅谷101的邀请，
然后我也是你们忠实的听众粉丝。
我之前上一份工作是在谷歌TPU组，
然后我也深度参与了三代TPU的研发。
相对近发布的Ironwood V7是我做的第二台TPU V8，
是我做的最后一代TPU，在我离职之前。
开心今天能跟大家分享一下我对TPU的一些理解吧。
首先我想说就是TPU是一个上下有产业链非常非常复杂的一个产品，
所以它是里面牵扯了很多软件硬件，包括代工，
所以里面很多很多记录系列是非常复杂的，
也是一个非常庞大的一个工业体系。
所以我也希望我今天只是根据我的理解去帮助大家。
更加解惑一下TPU这一层神秘的面纱吧。
你刚刚提到了你其实参与了V7跟V8的开发，
然后据我了解这个其实是谷歌的TPU，
他们开始去适应大模型的这种预性链，
最核心的，然后也是最有竞争力的这两代的芯片，
也是最新的两代，
因为你刚刚提到了它可能涉及到软件硬件，
然后包括代工生产，
所以今天我觉得我们可以从硬件软件生产环节，
每个环节都把它就是详细的pose一遍，
包括现在谷歌的TPU跟像Answerropic，
像Mata这些的合作，
我们可以看看它是如何影响到整个未来的英伟达的生态的。
最开始就是第一个问题，
很多人他并不清楚我们说TPU跟英伟达现在的，
比如说Gb200或者H100的GPU，
它有什么样的不一样，
我们可以先简单给听众介绍一下TPU跟GPU，
它的不同之处，
尤其是它在预讯链方向的不同之处。
我觉得首先TPU和GPU本身它的架构是完全不一样的，
然后GPU大家可能更加了解，
更加多一些，
因为它是最开始它是做游戏的显卡，
所以它里面会用到一个数字叫SIMT，
它是一个SIMT的架构，
Single Instruction Multiple Threading,。
它是个多线程单一指令的一个架构，
所以可以理解成一个厨房里面，
同时安排着很多很多个大厨，
它每个人都有自己独立的思考点力，
从冰箱里把东西拿出来，
然后做完菜，
然后最后上菜，
它会独立完成这样一件事情，
所以你安排很多很多大厨的话，
这样的话，
并行计算能力就会非常非常的强。
这个是GPU，
那如果我们同样用做菜来比喻TPU的话，
你觉得它的流程跟GPU有什么不一样？
TPU和GPU最大的区别就是TPU是一个。
针对机器学习的一个架构器，
我们知道机器学习任何的算法，
包括最开始的CN，
到现在的attention，
到transfermer,。
到未来的架构，
你们的核心就是矩阵计算，
我们知道矩阵计算这个东西，
是非常computable,。
是一个computing intensive的一个工作，
TPU的话就是针对这个矩阵计算，
专门做了一个定制的架构器，
所以你可以理解成，
做饭的话，
我们是一个流水线，
我们知道今天要做哪道菜，
然后TPU的话相当于是把，
不用安排那么多的大厨，
但是它会把大厨安排在。
每一个步骤上，
会把每一个步骤都，
告诉你具体做哪个步骤的火，
然后你做完之后直接把你，
你做完的比如说，
第一个人会从冰箱里把菜给取出来，
第二个人直接把，
第一个人做完的部分的中间菜的结果，
做架构，
传到第三个人，
然后相当于中间每一步骤，
你可以理解成是心脏的蹦血，
当你每蹦你之下，
就会把血液传送到你身体的各个角落，
所以这样的话，
中间它会少很多的掉度，
少很多的调控，
所以这样的话，
它能保证每一个计算单元的使用率，
会更高一些。
所以我理解，
其实就是TPU它是这种，
有点类似于并行的，
就是你每一个环节，
它是独立运行的，
然后TPU它是一场接力赛，
那在模型的训练上，
这两种就是不同的架构，
它的各自的优势，
跟缺点是什么？
我觉得现在预讯链，
包括后面的influence，
我们现在慢慢的从一个，
计算,
computer bound变成memory bound,。
所以我们现在，
对内存的要求是非常非常高的，
所以CMT它架构，
它有一个缺陷，
就是,
因为你需要，
独立的去做这样的计算的任务，
所以你有时候会一直在等，
数据搬赢过来的过程当中，
你就会有一些显致的idle period，
所以这个过程当中的话，
保持它的那个矩阵计算的利用率，
没有那么的高，
Utilization rate,。
就会有下降，
然后tpu,
就是根据这个特点，
然后,
弥补了这样一个缺点吧，
我这么觉得，
然后它相当于是，
我们当然可以具体了解一下，
它的软硬件的一个鞋筒，
那个效应，
它会保证，
它是一个满功率下的一个运行，
然后它不需要等待，
数据搬赢的过程，
它要么利用当地的缓存，
把一些提前，
搬运过来的数据重复去利用，
或者说，
把我们的带宽跑满，
让我们可以把那个Memory Utilization Rate，
能达到一个峰值。
所以,
如果整体上，
我们用一句话来去做结论的话，
你觉得tpu跟tpu，
他们在这个模型的训练上，
就是谁更强，
然后能优化多少？
我觉得，
从预讯令上来讲的话，
目前,
tpu和tpu最大预讯的就是，
当tpu现在也开始，
往那个方向去发展，
因为tpu一直做一个system level，
它是一个大的计算集群，
而不是单卡，
但芯片，
去做预讯令，
tpu可能很长一段时间都是，
单张卡的性能非常非常好，
但是它没有一个网络，
tpu一直是主打一个tpu pod，
它是一个有几千张卡的，
一个协同的一个训练的一个状态，
它里面牵扯到很多通信，
我们当时可以继续聊一下，
就是ICI,
就是interchip connect,。
它芯片与芯片的通信和，
和这个网络，
我们叫做3D Taurus，
一个tpu的一个网络，
它可以让几千张卡芯片，
它用户的感觉当中是一张卡的芯片，
但它中间训练效率是非常非常高的，
这样的话，
它的成本也是可以打得下来，
因为我是看新闻报道说，
谷歌V7的，
就是你研发的这一套，
Iron Ood,。
它的芯片，
它在物理参数上，
已经非常接近这个疾病200了，
所以它如果在真实的这个工作中，
或者我们这样说，
就是我们同样是训练一个Gemini的模型，
同样一代的模型，
同样的这个参数量，
那用tpu,
跟用谷歌的tpu，
谁更省钱？
对，我觉得是很好的问题，
我的理解是，
针对自家定制的大模型，
谷歌的话就是Gemini，
将来如果说，
谷歌给其他大公司，
Frontier大模型公，
定制的话，
我觉得谷歌，
性价比是更高的，
性价比我指的，
就是它的tco，
就total cost,。
all ownership,。
就是它的成本会更加有优势，
当你知道你的workout是什么时候，
你就可以根据你的workout去做一些，
不管是物理的，
芯片层面的一些定制，
或者说在软件层面去定制，
虽然说它可能有点黑河的感觉，
但是就是我知道，
相当给出了你所有的assumption，
你所有的一致条件都确定下来，
那我觉得tpu在现实生活中，
现实条件下，
它的训练效率还是tco，
都是会比tpu更加强大的，
刚才我提到这两点，
它的utrivation rate是更好的，
原因,
第一是它的flops，
它的flops我们指的就是，
单位时间内，
它做多少次，
浮点是运算，
对,
所以这样的话，
因为tpu它里面，
主要的架构就是矩阵计算，
所以它软件和硬件，
可以保证它每次，
每个时间，
每个计算单元，
它都有活在做，
我们的软件相当于，
是帮助硬件说，
哦,
我不会让你嫌下来，
每个时间等你都给我做活，
但是你具体做什么活，
是我告诉你的，
你不需要去精准地去预测，
或者怎么样，
所以,
它硬件层面说，
我们不会加很多的控制单元，
这跟tpu很大的区别，
就是我们不需要任何的prediction，
它prediction那一层level,。
相当于都是在软件层面去实现的，
对,
所以相当于，
你把硬件变得更蠢了一点，
相当于是一个机械式的劳作，
那边帮你把所有complexity都给处理掉，
所以这样的话，
Ironwood主要有两大的进步，
一个进步就是，
它把它的flops，
peak flops,。
数值上跟tpu更加接近了，
然后另外一个点，
我觉得非常非常重要，
就是它的memory bandwidth,。
也是有一个巨大的提升，
首先它肯定是用了更大的HBM，
保证了一定的带宽，
然后,
然后第二点就是，
这个HBM的带宽，
它能被软件充分地去利用起来，
更高线的HBM，
它现在在市场上，
从供应链的环节，
它好找货吗？
非常难找，
因为HBM的话，
首先它是一个非常非常，
有点,
有点垄断的一个感觉，
一共就三家公司垄断这个生产，
应该是SK Hynix，
三星和micron，
英语栏一直是HBM最大客户，
然后tpu的话，
一直是相当于是一个，
一个second rate的一个customer,。
所以你要跟那三家公司，
去确定一个订单的话，
我觉得是需要一个，
良性的可能关系，
之前的话，
tpu一直没有办法获得那么好的，
HBM,
或者说那么大的订单，
那现在谷歌tpu它的产量是多少？
具体数据我不是非常清楚，
但我觉得也是在一个慢慢的，
爬坡的过程当中，
谷歌tpu v7之前的话，
一直是有一个产能的问题，
我觉得也是一个，
很多因素导致的，
因为毕竟，
v7之前我们一直没有一个，
对外的一个生态，
我们更多是，
针对内部的一个deploy和使用，
所以我们没有办法和broadcom，
tsmc,
或者刚才所说的那几家，
HBM的厂商，
去锁定一个很大的一个订单，
因为产能都是提前一年，
或两年去锁定的，
当你没有那么大的客户，
或没有那么大的需求的话，
就是,
你临时想去调整，
是比较困难的一件事情，
然后第二点，
我觉得就是一个co-auth，
就是co-auth是tsmc的一个placity,。
我们可以理解成，
我们现在的芯片，
都是跟以前完全不一样，
因为我们现在都做一个co-design，
我们的HBM内存芯片，
和计算芯片，
是两块独立的芯片，
通过一个2.5D stacking的一个封装，
把它封装成一个计程芯片，
这个的话，
tpu,
Google自己做不了，
broadcom也做不了，
它只能依赖于tsmc，
可现在smc给你分配多少的产能，
你就能一年，
达成多少的产能，
所以tsmc,
它去分配产能的时候，
它也可能会看这个谷歌，
它要的量是多少，
如果你的量大的话，
比如说像英伟达，
它的量就比较大，
它是不是可能会先去做。
英伟达的量，
凭这个订单量说话，
然后你这个co-auth是指，
在它的整个的封装环节的一个部分，
就是我们可以，
把现在产能的瓶颈，
如果我们要去，
整体的总结一下，
就是你刚刚提到的co-auth，
跟tsmc,
这块是在封装上的一个产能，
然后还有一块就是HBM，
它是高带宽的内存供应，
然后这个可能也是一个瓶颈，
就是有三大垄断巨头去把持，
所以主要是，
产能主要是这两块，
卡在这两块上，
对,
还有一点就是量率，
量率的话就意味着，
当你tsmc,
把一个waiver带，
就是生产出来之后，
它上面这一块waiver上，
有多少是合格的芯片，
因为tpu和tpu它的，
制造理念是不太一样的，
tpu它更多是主导一个通信，
它是主导一个芯片与芯片之间的通信，
然后这样的话，
导致它的中间的失败率，
会比tpu会更高一些，
然后一旦失败了，
因为它要保证整个系统，
你每张芯片都是，
性能大致是一样的，
如果有存私不起的话，
它整个system跑下来的效率，
就不会有那么高，
但tpu可能就不存在，
太大这样的问题，
因为我们都知道tpu有自己，
严格的版本，
就是h100、a100,。
所以一旦良率不好的话，
它可以往下降级，
但是tpu不可以，
但你没有之前，
比如说你现在有v8，
然后你有v7，
你还有v6，
它不可以降级吗？
很难，因为是定制的芯片，
价格都会不太一样，
对，比较难，
不是通用的芯片，
所以一旦你良率不行的话，
就这一块芯片相当于爆废了，
所以相当于你产能就没办法，
一下子提上来。
所以这个是我们刚刚说到的，
就是生产环节中的，
然后生产环节取决于你的订单的量，
因为Anthoropic,。
它其实是有跟谷歌说，
我要采购你100万的tpu，
100万应该也是一个很大的量，
因为现在它的比如说，
gb200或者h100这些，
可能也是一个百万级，
到千万级，
所以其实我觉得谷歌现在看起来，
这个tpu已经是在蚕食这一块的市场份了。
对，我觉得，
我觉得tpu及gpu已经很难是。
同一个维度的去考量吧，
或去评价，
我觉得Anthoropic这一个订单，
确实是挺大的一个订单，
我觉得第一有很多的因素吧，
第一我觉得Anthoropic Google是一个，
相对于内循环，
因为Anthoropic很多投资方案也是Google，
所以我觉得Anthoropic Google是一个，
深度合作的一个关系，
相当于如果说是Mata，
或者其他的公司的话，
我不确定它的成本，
它的tco到底能不能压得下来，
然后第二点的话，
我觉得就是Anthoropic，
它的工程式的技术能力，
还是非常非常强的，
所以他们能去用tpu来部署。
他们自己的自家的模型，
然后就我们刚刚可以详细了一下，
为什么tpu的部署在一般。
external third party customer上那么的难,。
但我觉得Anthoropic目前来讲，
是有这样一个谷歌的生态的，
我是这么觉得，
所以Anthoropic拿下这个订单，
我觉得有时有很多因素在里面，
那我们就顺着继续讲一下Anthoropic，
它是不是跟谷歌的整个的软件生态有关系，
因为我们说在tpu上要搭一层软件，
然后我听说过这样一个说法，
就是说，
因为Anthoropic他们的很多人，
最开始是在Google的，
所以他们其实是非常了解，
tpu上的这一套软件生态的部署的，
所以他们可以用tpu去训练模型，
回答这个问题之前，
你可以先简单聊一下XLA吧，
因为我觉得XLA也是Google的一个，
你可以理解成黑盒，
也可以理解成是一个secret sauce，
对，我觉得XLA和库达最大区别，
XLA是一个静态的一个编译器，
然后静态编译指的就是，
当你的workload是已知的，
或者给定的话，
它可以带一个全局的tpu pod，
一个system level,。
它可以把它做一个全局的优化，
优化分很多层面，
我知道他们会做很多内部的算子融合，
比如说你一个kernel里面有很多计算，
然后你还会把一些计算，
和平到一个计算单元，
一个算子，
这样的话你能更好的去利用你的。
systolic array里面的矩阵计算的利用率，
然后你中间的中间态结果，
你不用反复的存进内存，
存出来，
XLA会帮你自动做这样的优化，
然后它还会做很多的一些内存的管理，
怎么去更好地去吩咐你的内存，
它知道tpu喜欢怎么从内存里面去把处给读出来，
这些想法都是跟硬件架构，
和一些具体的细节是非常非常相符相成的，
所以XLA会通过黑盒帮你去优化这样的一件事情，
但问题就是这个事情，
你是没办法去很好地debug和去控制的，
对，就开发者他很难去用XLA这套系统，
然后一个是编程语言，
他们不会对吧，
他用的是什么编程语言？
这样XLA它是一个编辑器，
它上层是pytoch,jax和tensor flow,。
然后你的开发者你可以写任何一样的语言，
然后它通过XLA可以把你转化成tpu的assembly code，
就是tpu的指令，
它中间是做一个翻译的工作，翻译加优化，
所以如果对应英伟达的话，
对应的就是枯大的整个生态体系，
对,
那我们说，我们刚刚提到，
其实AnswerRopic他们是有工程师去懂XLA的这套体系的，
然后AnswerRopic他现在应该已经是用谷歌的tpa。
去趁了一些模型，对不对，
就已经有这样的一些成果了，
因为我们知道在tpu去训练模型的过程中，
工程师经常会遇到的问题，
就是说他有一个bug，
然后我需要去解决他，
然后我需要在他的软件的编辑器上，
比如说枯大的生态上，
去看看是哪个环节出了问题，
然后把它解决掉，
那现在如果是用谷歌的tpu出了问题，
刚刚你也提到了XLA，
它是一个黑盒，
那要怎么去解决呢？
是必须找谷歌的工程师来解决，
还是他们自己就可以解决？
你可以理解成XLA是黑盒，
但它里面有很多很多的光终影去debug的一些工具，
一些function,。
但那问题就是，
你需要对硬件是有一些了解，
你才能更好地去分析它，
因为XLA它会把很多算做融合，
然后内存做管理，
这样的话，
它是一个graph，
它不是一个单个的计算，
它是一个链条，一个图表，
所以相当于你这样debug起来，
它对工程师的要求会更，
它是可以debug，
但对工程师的要求会更高一些，
所以Enzo Ropio找你们了嘛，
在训练的过程中，
因为一旦发现XLA的bug，
你就必须让Google的工程师来去帮忙去分析去解决，
如果真的是个bug需要去解决，
就外部的开发者很难独立去处理一个，
或者fix一个bug，
不想枯大的话，
是有一个很好的生态你可以去，
对对对，
所以你们大概比如说，
因为有卖一些tpu给Enzo Ropio，
你们会有多少人的一个工程师团队去，
支持他们这个，
就是项目中遇到的各种bug的问题，
我是做硬件嘛，
我们有很多软件组专门去对接不同的，
不同的客户，
像我们现在可能，
之前他们是有Apple，
有Majorny,。
然后Enzo Ropio,。
他们都是会有很多很多的request，
就是我离职之前的话，
也听说他们很多很多的非常非常忙，
是的是的是的，
我昨天听说就是，
用谷歌的tpu最大的团队，
其实不是Enzo Ropio，
虽然他们下了一个100万的订单，
之前模型上也有用过，
最大的团队其实是苹果，
然后苹果是因为，
就是庞若铭之前在这个Google，
然后他去苹果的时候，
他就是相当于把谷歌的一整套带过去了，
然后就直接用的这个tpu，
去训练他们的这个弹幕性，
我觉得也牵涉到一个，
软件栽的迁移嘛，
就是你要用tpu的话，
你必须要把原来的一套软件栽，
全部迁移到jaxxla上，
如果你不迁移的话，
你当然可以去做他能跑，
但你就利用不到tpu那么好的性能和tco，
就要把他的性能栽干，
对对,
因为如果现在目前tpu，
相比gpu,
他最大优势就是他，
他成本控制的很好，
相比起芯片，
他更多是依赖于软件。
那你觉得，
Google的这个jamminite他的模型，
因为他现在是，
应该是市场上最好的模型，
他的训练出来，
跟tpu的关系有多大？
我觉得是关系是很大的，
能占决定性因素吗？
还是算法其实是占决定性因素的一部分？
算法当然很重要，
因为我觉得现在就是，
训练,
特别是pre-training,。
他kpax很大，
然后他算法我觉得，
dmi那边有非常非常前沿的算法，
tpu能帮你去做的一件事情，
当你有一个很好的算法之后，
然后你提前跟tpu的沟通好，
我是怎么样的一个算法，
我怎么样的国附的，
我给你去定制这样的一个加速器，
这样我能，
帮助你的一个更短的时间，
更快的迭代，
去测试这样一套算法。
我这是一个很重要的一个事情，
就是,
如果说你的训练效率很差的话，
你需要发更长的周期，
去验证一套算法是否能work，
但tpu如果能把你的时间打下来之后的话，
迭代速度或你都会更快一些，
对,
你们定制这样的一个芯片，
大概要多久流程？
对,
我觉得这是非常，
这是一个任何芯片公司的一个痛点吧，
包括tpu,
包括gpu,
他们很多的时候，
都是在预测未来市场的变化，
包括预测未来模型的变化，
之前知道，
就是moe的话，
也是很早就是有这样的一个想法，
moe很长一段时间在tpu和tpu上跑的效果，
都不是特别好，
但是后来tpu增加了，
和软件一起增加了，
对moe的优化，
那是哪一年？
应该是v4 v5，
v4 v5,
那好早啊，
应该是在模型，
模型初端，
刚刚开始出来的时候，
对对对，具体，
那是2022年，
2023年,
对对，那太早了，
可以详细介绍一下，
就是为什么，
之前moe一直在tpu上跑不去，
而原因就是因为，
它是一个2D tower，
相当于，
你每个tpu的芯片，
只能跟它的neighbor，
相当于tpu芯片做通信，
它不是一个autual的一个communication，
这意味着，
如果说moe的话，
它还有一个routing的一个face，
它需要把它的routing给不同的专家，
它不同专家，
分布在不同的芯片上，
所以如果说，
你没有一个autual的connection的话，
你这样的话，
中间你就相当于，
你要找一个朋友，
你中间要经过很多的环节，
经过很多这样的话，
有很多的浪费，
很多的拥堵，
然后后来，
在v4的时候，
tpu推出了一个叫做3D towers，
它用了一个叫做ocs，
一个光签的一个交换机，
相当于这是一个software programmable,。
configured的一个交换机，
相当于的话，
你带一个tpu pod的一个节点，
你可以通过软件，
来更改你想通信的那个，
tpu机群的一个路径，
这样的话就相当于，
一下子把moe的一个，
一个痛点给去解决了，
然后之后的话，
moe就在tpu上跑起来，
效率就会明显比之前高很多，
所以我理解这个迭代是，
以年来计算的，
因为你设计出来了，
还要量产对吧，
量产的节奏一般是多久啊，
半年,
半年打得下来吗？
打不下来，
对,
我觉得看就是，
每家公司的philosophy都不一样，
像tpu的话，
一直都是主打说，
我一定要做一个旗舰的，
一个training chip,。
或旗舰的influence chip,。
一直以来都是这样的一个想法，
所以说，
这对快速迭代要求，
会非常非常高，
因为你每一代新片，
都会塞很多很多样的request，
然后,
相当于整个流程，
当你设计完，
然后我们会做验证，
然后再交给blogcom，
去做通信上面的那些，
设计,
然后在整个package level，
再做验证，
最后交给gsmp，
我觉得整个流程，
最快最快，
也要两年到两年半，
三年,
所以我们今天看到的，
就是你刚刚提到谷歌，
已经更新到，
vcv8的这一款了，
这一款我理解，
它在设计上，
它是两年以前就做了，
但是我们说，
就是模型的更新，
包括模型里面，
大家核心的这个算法，
往哪个方向走，
最近我觉得，
基本上是每六个月，
可能就会变化一次，
就是说，
你要在两年前去预测，
两年以后的模型，
它在往哪个方向走，
压对了吗？
目前来讲，
v7应该是压对了，
这个是为什么，
可以解释一下，
为什么之前，
tpu芯片和tpu的，
纸面参数上，
是有一些挺大的距离的，
因为之前tpu的，
主要的work load,。
是内部的一些，
recommendation,。
和ranking system的算法,。
所以它可能没有想到，
tpt出来之后，
有这样一个大的需求，
和对算力上，
一个那么大的一个需求，
它针对recommendation,。
和ranking是完全不一样的，
work load,。
所以它里面，
我之前我参与，
也是设计了一道，
一个模块叫做spot score，
稀书计算的一个模型，
它是专门针对，
一个recommendation的一个embedding,。
它这个layer的一个，
一个算法，
做了一个特定的优化，
但那个优化里面，
它没有很稠密的矩阵计算，
它更多是，
比较稀书的矩阵计算，
所以我们会针对它，
我们做了很多算法，
所以它牺牲掉，
一些那个矩阵的，
那个算数的密度，
感觉个GPU好像，
做矩阵计算完比GPU，
更好了一点，
是V级的版本，
那时候应该是V4V5，
V4V5,对,
它开始把它所有的，
这个核心性能，
往大模型的预训链上，
调试哪一代，
然后是哪一年，
对，应该就是V6吧，
V6开始的，
V6开始我记得，
应该是做了两个版本，
一个是专门做训练，
一个专门做influence，
对，训练和influence，
其实本质上，
他们是用的是同一道架构，
influence可以理解成是，
训练芹片的一条字极吧，
它可以有更小的，
应算单元，
它可以有更小的内存，
因为,
相比确定的话，
influence它不需要，
做back propagation,。
反向传播，
所以它不需要，
很多的那种中间，
不需要存储很多的，
那个副本，
差不多是在，
也是在两年多，
两三年以前，
去开始调整这个方向的，
其实GPT,
它是在，
2020年,
它就有一个版本放出来，
当时是GPT3嘛，
就谷歌那个时候，
它已经开始，
就是意识到这是一个，
next big scene,。
然后它有去做，
这个芹片上的调整，
或是tpu上的调整，
对，其实谷歌很早就开始，
因为transformers,。
也是谷歌出来的嘛，
谷歌很早就开始，
知道transformers这套架构，
然后,
根据这套架构，
我们芹片组，
我们也知道，
我们会去，
做这一套架构的一些，
去优化，
包括tension kernel,。
就很早就已经，
在内部里面，
这样说我突然想起来，
就是我觉得，
谷歌的tpu，
到现在，
它能在整个的模型，
预讯链中，
性能表现非常的优秀，
也是因为transformers,。
这套架构，
是谷歌发明的，
然后从tpu的这个，
诞生开始，
它就一直走的是，
这一条的路径，
所以,
我们其实，
也可以把tpu，
理解成一个，
针对于大模型，
预讯链，
或者推理的asic，
这样说是对的吧，
没问题呢，
对，然后你这个asic，
就一定要压对方向，
它压到了transformers,。
没问题，对，
对,
因为我觉得，
有点insider news的感觉，
是的，是的，是的，
我们知道，
transformers,。
大概模型什么，
比起行业外，
我们更早的知道，
这样的一手信息，
更早知道，
它是怎么样的一个workload，
所以,
我们相当于是有，
一个先发的优势，
但我们的问题，
就是,
本质上asic和tpu，
它就是一个，
是通用性好，
一个通用性不好，
就是说，
即使我们有一手的信息，
但是,
你一旦确定了asic，
它是要去改变的，
所以说，
tpu剩就剩在，
它,
因为现在，
模型迭代周期，
非常非常短，
都是以，
越来做单位，
是的,
所以,
一旦你的芯片价格，
固定下来之后，
你一旦有一个，
新的算法上的，
一个动态，
一个改变的话，
你在tpu上，
就很难去实现，
这样一件事情，
即使你有先发优势，
但后面的竞争，
会越来越激烈，
这样的话，
你的先发优势，
可能也会慢慢被蚕食，
我觉得有一个阶段，
模型的迭代速度，
会比tpu更快一些。
那现在是哪个阶段，
tpu更快?
目前V7,
是感觉跟tpu black，
blackquare,。
已经是旗鼓相当了，
旗鼓相当，
v8呢?
v8,
目前不能透露，
对,
但是,
记录细节，
肯定是不能透露，
但是,
我刚刚提到moe，
这样一个架构，
tpu在芯片，
或通信层面，
随随live,
它就解决这样一个问题，
但是我担忧的一点，
就是,
这一套架构，
它的scalability,。
有多强？
如果说将来，
有一个完全不同的，
一个饭式，
完全不同的，
一个模型，
然后,
你没办法在tpu上，
做这样的去优化，
对,
然后,
tpu上可以，
是的,
对,
这样的话，
你并质芯片，
因为tpu团队，
跟tpu是不是一个量级的，
你没办法做一个快速的迭代，
这样的话，
你的性能上差距，
可能就会被拉打，
所以我觉得，
这个很难去评判，
现在,
可能是我对tpu的一个担忧，
就是,
万一将来，
有一个不同的饭式，
它怎么去，
跟上tpu的部分？
我们刚刚提到了，
就是,
如果,
整个大模型，
它的训练饭式，
变了,
然后,
就会影响到整个tpu，
它的销量，
你的这个饭式，
指的是，
就是有多大的饭式调整，
我可以举个例子，
就比如说，
如果,
我们整个，
以transformer,。
为底层架构的，
这样的一个饭式，
变了的话，
就没用了，
对吧,
我可以，
可以这样说，
不完全准确，
就是transformer,。
它核心还是矩阵计算，
对,
矩阵计算的，
如果这样的一个，
但这样应该不会，
应该不会，
对,
但是,
我们就说，
如果出现了，
类似于不同意transformer的，
新的架构，
那tpu,
它就不一定有这个，
tpu它的表现好，
那如果是，
在模型层面，
就像你刚刚说的，
比如说，
moe的,
一些新的方法的微调，
但它还是基于，
整个transformer的,。
这种你觉得，
tpu未来,
它还是会，
持续的占优势吗，
包括大家现在，
很热的说，
我要用这个rl的方式，
去做agent的训练，
或者去做模型的训练，
就是rl对tpu的影响，
会大吗？
啊,
我觉得，
肯定是会，
会是不一样的workload的，
肯定是会有影响，
就是,
我觉得像tpu的测的优势，
是把芯片变得更加的通用，
我也是，
带往这样一个方向去发展，
相当于它举证单元，
它可以处理各种workload的，
举证计算，
它也有专门负责，
去处理一些，
稀疏的举证计算的，
一些单元，
它可以理解成，
把很多硬件上的，
一些计算和那种模块化，
来适应将来不同的，
那个方式，
所以从某种意义上来讲，
也是一个，
像通用性的一些妥协，
对,
我觉得，
之前一往几大芯片，
可能设计的没有那么激进的原因，
也是,
有一部分的考量，
就是,
如果一旦你设计得非常激进，
你可以在jammer上模型效率，
可以提升个30-40%，
但万一有变换呢，
万一有变换，
那你回去的话，
你就会非常非常的痛苦，
所以我觉得，
这是一种，
基于现实的一种compromise，
我觉得，
然后我们刚刚提到了，
就是整个在适应新的算法方向的，
从设计层面的调整，
那还有一个，
我觉得谷歌，
最近也比较用力的，
就是在软件层，
让整个的中间的软件，
能够适应更多的开发者的调整，
我最近是看到一条新闻，
说这个，
谷歌跟meta，
也有一个这样的tpu的采购协议，
然后谷歌向meta，
提供这种tpu的，
托管的服务，
但是呢，
就是他可能核心想做的，
就是把pi-touch，
变成这个，
tpu的一个中间层，
类似于像谷歌的枯大生态，
这样的一个，
就是比如说，
在做编译器的时候，
可以用pi-touch来编译，
我有了解，
但具体的细节，
还没有公开嘛，
所有的meta，
都是用pi-touch，
大家应该是，
众所周知，
所以,
但pi-touch,。
刚才我有提到，
它跟tpu的生态，
其实不是特别的兼容，
所以它很难，
像安刷片那样，
它也做一个深度的一个，
对tpu整个，
软件生态的一个使用，
目前来讲，
我觉得它可能，
更多是，
一拖于谷歌云，
谷歌cloud,。
提供更多的算力，
因为,
包括,
今年它其实，
股价不是那么好的原因，
也是一个kpass，
还是太大了，
它对特别预讯链，
这一块的成本支出，
实在是，
需求非常非常的大，
它已经把市面上，
所有能买来的算力，
都买来了，
去做这样一件事情，
所以我觉得，
tpu的台湾，
目前来讲，
也是去帮它，
去offload一些，
它至于方面的一些压力，
软件态的话，
pi-touch,。
很早之前，
就跟tpu,
包括,
fair那个团队，
也跟tpu都有接洽，
就说能不能，
在tpu上,
更好的去支持pi-touch，
这样的话，
我们也更好的去，
做一些research的开发，
但目前来讲，
我觉得谷歌，
也是有在去，
做一些改变了，
离职之前，
也知道有很多组，
在做pi-touch,。
和xla的结合，
包括,
在xla和tpu上，
支持很多，
native的一些，
pi-touch的一些library,。
一些并行的library，
和一些算子，
因为现在pi-touch，
这些算子，
太多了，
可能有，
好几千个算子，
如果你不在，
硬件上，
原生的去支持，
这些算子的话，
你的性能，
表现就会，
比较差一些。
那所以，
如果大家，
直接用谷歌云呢？
当然可以，
但,
问题是什么？
问题就是，
直接用谷歌云的话，
相当于你把，
你相当于，
脱管了，
你没办法，
做很多底层的去控制，
如果你想去，
挖掘,
每一分的性能的话，
你跟谷歌云，
就没办法，
去做这样的事情，
会有浪费，
会在一个多少的，
百分比？
这个很难说，
多少到多少，
一个大概的比例，
比如说，
百分之五十，
它可能是一个，
非常大的浪费，
百分之十，
它会稍微小一点，
对,
这有时候，
刚才说到，
就是那个，
model utilization rate,。
如果说，
你集合得非常好的话，
你能,
几乎,
满状态的，
带到一个peak flops，
或peak memory bandwidth,。
但如果，
你跟谷歌云来跑的话，
你很有可能，
就是可能，
用到只有百分之五十，
百分之六十，
还是挺大的，
对,
所以现在，
mata跟谷歌的合作，
反正我是看新闻报道，
我觉得，
好像是，
在这个，
谷歌的，
谷歌云上跑，对吧？
对,对,
目前我知道，
直接购买，
tpu机架的rack，
直接从proc.com购买，
应该只有srp，
其他都还是，
目前还是谷歌云，
哦,
所以,
苹果跟majorny，
也是在谷歌云上跑的，
嗯,
那这样也简单，
就从谷歌照工程师过去，
对，对，对，对，对，
人才的流动，
所以谷歌的工程师，
现在应该，
就是还挺吃香的，
对,
我觉得，
如果将来，
有很多更多的第三方，
加入的话，
特别是jax.xlh，
其实是一个，
非常非常，
高技术壁垒的，
一个,
一个工作版，
所以,
特别是，
我觉得，
如果之前在谷歌，
有这样的经验的话，
能更好的歉意过去，
对,
多长时间能学会，
一个工程师，
哈哈哈，
还是挺难的，
挺难的，
因为,
需要了解硬帧，
需要了解软件，
它是一个附合机能，
附合机能，对，
然后我们看到，
就是在今年，
就是,
包括,
就是之前，
就很多开发者，
他在调这个大模型的，
API接口的时候，
其实我注意到，
谷歌的这个，
API接口的成本，
大概最开始，
是只有，
OpenAI,
跟AzureOpic的,。
十分之一，
同时呢，
这个AzureOpic,。
它最近的，
四点五，
它的这个API接口，
大概是下降了，
百分之六十七，
然后我看有媒体报道，
把这一部分的，
功劳归功于，
它是用谷歌的这个，
tpu-twin的,。
所以这个是，
这两者是直接相关的，
可以说，
在推理成本上，
推理成本上，
确实是这样的，
我觉得，
Google,
它现在的，
推理芯片成本，
确实会比GPU，
要高不少，
它的原因就是，
刚刚所说，
它是一个集群的，
一个推理，
它的tco,
就能打得下来，
刚才没有提到，
一点就是，
GPU的集群，
它用的是，
一种envlink,。
envswitch,。
这样的一种，
一通信协议，
这个其实，
很少钱，
它是一个，
你可以理解成，
是一种infrastructure的,。
一种text,
所以,
你需要跟很多，
不同厂商去，
买这种交换机，
然后部署在你的，
数据中心当中，
是一个很大的成本，
开始,
Google,
因为它用了，
它不一样的一个，
tpu-twin架构,。
它用了一个是，
芯片与芯片之间，
直接通信，
它用的是个筒，
它不用交换机，
直接接点上，
用一些光学交换机，
它也比较少，
然后,
实现了同样的，
一个通信的效果，
所以,
它在一个成本支出上，
就是,
会比gpu要好很多，
所以,
就是,
我理解，
在建数据中心的这一环，
成本已经拉开了，
已经拉开了，
vdl的主要成本是，
交换机，
嗯,
我了解到，
他们在搭的，
整个的这个芯片机群里面，
还要铺很多的桶，
是不是，
是不是他们都是用，
这种桶的这个线，
来连接起来的，
对,
那谷歌的主要成本，
是什么呢，
是夜冷的，
夜冷是某一块吧，
夜冷是一块，
然后,
其实跟英伟达也，
也差不太多，
它也主要成本，
也是它的一些，
surdice,。
它的那个，
我们会跟brocon，
深度合作一些，
这种surdice,。
就让于是，
把信号，
从一个芯片，
准确无辜，
传输到另外一个芯片，
因为,
相比gpu的话，
tpu,
它更多依赖surdice的，
一个稳定性，
所以它的那一块，
资本去出来，
你们跟brocon的，
这个合作，
会持续多久，
还是它是根据量来的，
如果量大了，
谷歌可能就自己做了，
对对,
因为现在市面上，
有两家公司，
跟,
做这样的代工，
一家是brocon，
另外一家是marvel，
然后brocon和marvel,。
对它去的就是，
brocon有点像2B，
它是一个2B的一个business，
它就锁定，
一个最大的客户，
然后跟他们，
做深度的合作和定制，
然后marvel的话，
可能更多是，
跟一些，
中型,
或一些start-up，
可能说，
提供一个IP的一个solution，
它可能不会，
跟你的模型，
去深度去定制一些硬件，
但它可能会做一个量，
然后brocon,。
它好处就是，
可以帮它最大的客户，
去争取最大的产能，
就是coos,
tsmc,
所以说，
一直以来，
tpu都是,
跟brocon去做这样一个合作，
也是,
目前我不觉得，
会有很大的改变，
但,
这样导致的一个不好的问题，
就是,
brocon的一家全会越来越大，
所以你在中间，
tpu能转的margin,。
也会越来越少，
是的,
对,
如果你非常依赖brocon，
然后你没有一个backup的话，
就是,
有点像tpu和tpu的关系，
一直以来，
tpu是,
tpu的一个backup,。
也是有，
一家全的考量在里面，
所以如果你没有一个backup的话，
你,
在成本上就很难，
控制得下来，
所以我觉得，
这也是将来，
可以关注的一个点，
所以谷歌，
它能直接跟coos，
这一块来一家吗？
决定的核心要素，
是什么？
coos主要还是HBM，
就是我们的内存的一个封装，
所以,
这样的话，
相当于，
我的理解是brocon，
是一个中间的环节，
它会把所有的东西，
全部,
帮你铺设好，
然后它交给TSMT，
去量产，
所以我觉得，
第一，你需要去拿到一个很高的，
很好的一个，
HBM的一个capacity,。
再通过brocon，
去跟TSMT,
争取一个好的coos，
我听说，
现在整个HBM的capacity，
被英伟打垄断了，
基本是垄断了，
对,
因为刚才有提到，
因为HBM,
现在我们已经慢慢从，
computer bound,。
名称memory bound,。
特别是，
现在的attention kernel,。
它其实，
核心就是一个，
你怎么样去更快的，
从内存里把数据，
给搬运出来，
因为它的KB caching，
它里面有很多数据的，
一些搬运，
未来几年的方向，
可能就是HBM，
能决定了你的上限，
如果你还缺，
如果你买不到好的HBM的话，
你的群联效率，
就会,
会大家折扣。
所以,
博通的主要核心的作用，
是在这一块？
博通主要的核心作用，
它是做很多的通信，
ICI Interchip Connect,。
然后,
它会做很多的后端，
因为我们芯片的话，
我们tpu,
团队主要，
设计它的前端，
比如说，
我们相当于是，
把一张图纸，
给打印出来，
然后brocon,。
会把每个芯片，
芯片之间，
物理上，
去连接起来，
然后最后，
交付给TSMC，
所以brocon,。
更多是做一个，
信号的连接，
怎么去，
布局这样一个，
tpu的一个网络，
所以brocon,。
可能是在这一边，
也是挺核心的一个环节，
非常核心，
而且是一个技术壁垒，
非常非常高的一个环节，
因为现在目前，
一旦信号里面有，
有问题的话，
那整个机型就不能用了，
所以这是一个，
你可以理解成，
脏活泪活，
但你也可以理解成，
这是一个，
非常非常，
吃惊艳的，
也是技术壁垒，
非常非常高的，
因为brocon他们那边的话，
主要是一个，
一个,
复合的一个信号，
我们,
tpu,
tpu都是一个数字电路，
但那个是一个mix signal，
是一个，
一个模拟电路，
加数字电路，
所以它对，
它对,
经验要求会更高一些。
这是,
如果我们用一句话来总结，
你觉得，
现在谷歌的tpu，
可以挑战英伟达的，
在tpu的垄断地位吗？
或者说，
至少是，
我去阻挠一下这个，
英伟达在这个市场上，
绝对的定价权，
没有绝对的答案，
但我的结论是，
呃,
在某些限定的条件下，
如果一旦，
满足了这些限定条件，
我觉得tpu是完全可以，
挑战tpu的，
限定条件就是，
一个大规模部署，
因为tpu,
它主要就是走量，
如果说，
呃,tpu,
它其实不太擅长，
做一件事情就是，
它没办法，
针对一个单用户，
比如说做agent，
它就不太适合，
因为它颜值会比较高一些，
啊,
推理信片也不行是吧，
呃,
现在的提升，
但是它比起像groke，
比起因为单，
它的,
它的可塑性就没有那么强，
所以它必须带一个，
非常大的一个吞吐量下，
比如说有很多很多用户，
同时去，
呃，去调用这个接口，
很多很多用户，
同时去用jammer，
然后下GPT，
它才能把这个成本，
给分摊开来，
这样的话，
它能得到一个，
很好的一个吞吐量，
所以在这种情况下，
大规模部署，
然后模型相对比较稳定，
它不需要很多的变动，
这样的话，
它的整体的成本，
都相比GPU有很大的优势，
但我的总结就是，
当然如果你的模型，
相对比较固定，
不需要很多的改变，
然后它的形态，
也是比较静态的形态，
TPU是非常适合，
去大规模部署的，
比如说你已经训练好了，
一套模型，
然后你只需要去做imference，
TPU它的一个system level,。
的优化能力，
软硬件协动能力，
能帮助你的这一套模型，
能把成本，
控制在一个，
非常好的一个，
一个范围之内，
这也是TPU最大的优势，
但它有它的前提，
就是它必须是一个，
非常大的用户在用，
很多的用户在用，
它不太适合，
去做本地的部署，
然后它很适合，
在云上去用，
很适合，
比如说你jamminite，
chatgbt,。
cloud,
这种,
每天都有Millions of users,。
这样的话，
它会把成本，
分摊给每个user，
但如果它去做推理的话，
它的延迟，
会有多少，
就跟普通的，
这种,
GPU相关的，
这些agent来比，
大家可以去看，
它官方的documentation,。
它延迟做的，
也是非常非常不错的，
但它没有写的，
就是,
它需要有一个大用户，
它我们内部，
会有一个batch，
就是,
你可以理解成，
有多少个queer，
多少个request，
你如果每一秒，
你没有很多，
足够多的用户的话，
它TPU没办法，
软件,
把它打包成，
一个很大的，
一个矩阵计算，
然后就很好的，
去计算的，
计算密度，
如果你只有，
你一个用户的话，
那你的成本就会很高了，
就是用户规模数越大，
它反而越快，
即使在推理上，
也是这样，
就是如果你是一个，
非常小的，
这种创业公司，
那大家可以用，
谷歌云接入，
然后我跟，
其他的request，
打包吗？
因为sroop,。
它其实有两个，
性能的指标，
一个是吞吐量，
就是sroop,。
市面上，
比较讨论，
比较多的token per second,。
token,
还有另外一个，
就是我们的，
那个伪布延迟，
就critical pass,。
那个latency,。
它可以保证一个，
非常快的响应速度，
然后每一个token，
token之间,。
它的latency,。
都非常非常低延迟的，
所以我觉得，
这一块的话，
tpu是不太适合，
去做这种，
非常非常快的响应速度，
但它可以适合做，
就是,
它每秒成人100token，
但是,
有些用户，
可能稍微慢一点点，
然后有没有用户，
快一点，
它保证一个平均值，
这是它能做到的一件事情，
谷歌的jamline，
它是不是所有的模型，
全部是用tpu迅的，
还是它也会有加入tpu？
v7的发布，
基本上是说，
100%是用tpu,。
但是在v7之前，
tpu一直是tpu的backup,。
原因也很简单，
XLA加GX是一套，
非常复杂，
非常不稳定的，
一个套，
软件生态，
它很多时候，
会容易去抱错，
一旦抱错，
它的pre-training,。
它的风险是很大的，
现在我觉得，
这套系统已经非常stadia，
也非常成熟了，
在之前不成熟的时候，
你就需要用tpu来做backup，
所以之前一直是tpu和tpu混着，
混着用，
运用训练，
并不意味着tpu训练效果，
没有tpu好，
只是意味着它的整个season，
它的稳定性，
还没有达到一个
非常好的一个状态，
我听说，
现在谷歌内部的jamline，
就是非常缺tpu，
因为我有时候，
用它模型的时候，
它会说，
这个请求过多，
然后就挂了，
这应该是没有卡，是吧？
对，就是没有卡，
这个情况会持续多久，
GT不是非常清楚，
但是现在可能，
就是大家一下子，
因为我也看到了，
大家用户，
很多都从下级，
比较迁移到jamline了，
对,
人家满足这样的，
很大用户的一个migration的话，
确实硬件上，
需要Ramp Appearance,。
刚我们提到了，
其实它是有独立的。
训练芯片，
跟独立的推理芯片的，
哪个现在的量更大，
对，是这样，就是，
对，我其实，
就是如果不说，
具体数据也没有关系，
我其实是想给，
听众一个大概的印象，
就是想让大家看一下，
这个训练跟推理，
它们各自的，
大概的一个比例，
跟综合情况是怎样的？
因为,
RM5的其实，
它是一款，
主要针对infront推理芯片的，
一个性能上的，
一个优化的芯片，
它当然可以做训练，
但它里面，
很多的一些，
核心的黑科技，
是针对，
我们现在，
当下的一个推理，
推理的，
一个应用的市场，
所以它，
比起训练，
它要求的那些，
指标,
RM5的更多是，
它要保证一个低延迟，
保证一个大的存土量，
保证你的memory bandwidth,。
是足够大的，
这样的话，
你做LM,
特别在deco那个环节，
你不会被内存那边，
卡住,
所以说，
我觉得这也是一种，
信号,
就是说谷歌，
觉得未来，
包括整个市场，
我觉得未来，
对infront这个，
这样的潜力，
还是非常非常看好的，
但pre-training,。
也是非常重要的一个环节，
因为谷歌作为，
少数几家，
做frontier大模型的公司，
他们一直以来，
他们的，
philosophy,。
就是,
我设计一款芯片，
首先是，
要把training做好。
综上,
我们所有所说的，
我试着总结一下，
这个tpu,
跟tpu的优势，
跟劣势，
就是,
整体来看，
现在tpu,
它在性能上，
包括在模型的训练上，
就如果你用的好的话，
你是可以把它跑满的，
它可能会，
达到这个tpu的性能，
甚至是比它，
跑的更好，
然后,
在数据中心的部署上，
它是更省成本的，
这个是它的一些核心优势，
同时就是，
用了它，
你的推理成本可以降低，
那它的缺点，
就是,
首先我们说，
在这个软件的生态上，
XLA,
它还是一个，
比较难入门的，
这样的一个核心门看，
它没有因为，
达到这个，
枯打它的这个生态，
另外一点，
就是,
整个的齐量上，
包括对这个HBM，
它的供应链的控制上，
还是比较弱的，
还有一个核心的问题，
就是说，
如果大家使用了tpu，
但是你内部没有特别懂的人，
它还是一个黑盒，
就是你没有办法，
用自己的工程师，
去把它调优，
然后把它的性能跑满，
然后如果用谷歌语的话，
可能只能跑到这个，
50%到60%的性能，
在这种情况下，
它跟tpu,
谁的性能更好，
现在其实，
也是一个很难说的话题，
所以整体上，
我们看到是这样的一个趋势，
然后,
tpu最大的核心的问题，
就是说，
未来如果整个模型，
它在架构跟算法上有升级，
它类似于一款专用的ASIC芯片，
那通用的tpu是更有优势的，
但是如果你们的算法，
堵对了，
你们就是有核心优势的。
我的总结准确，
我觉得非常惊奇。
那,
其实我们前面，
聊了这么多的tpu，
就是你要不要跟大家，
再简单的回溯一下，
就是谷歌，
是怎么样去发明这个tpu的，
它的一个历史是什么，
然后谁是中间的核心人物？
对,
我们最开始tpu的话，
主要是针对内部CNN最大模型的一个，
一个架构器，
然后最开始，
第一代芯片，
它只是一款influenced芯片，
因为刚才我也提到，
influenced相比Train,。
更好做一些，
所以influenced相当于是一个testing chip，
就作为一个入口，
我们先把这个，
它里面的架构，
相对比较简单，
它就是一个矩身计算机，
加内存，
没有其他更多的一些模块，
然后最开始的初衷，
就是大家发现，
我们内部有很多的。
online recommendation system,。
但它的influenced,。
都是用cpu来做influenced，
大家都知道cpu，
什么样的问题，
对,
它的并行效果是非常非常差的，
然后那时候也没办法用cpu，
因为今天那时候cpu，
它还没有加入它的那个矩身计算单元，
所以它更多是一个做显卡，
做一个pixel，
是的,
所以那时候，
没有更好用的芯片，
所以在谷歌说，
为什么不自己开发一款，
只做矩的计算的模型，
所以最开始初衷，
应该是jeff dink,。
后来土临奖的获得者，
Dev Paterson,。
也是深度参与了，
第一代模型的架构，
所以设计出来，
性能非常非常的好，
我们有了第二代芯片，
第二代芯片，
它就是一个，
非常旗舰的做，
做training,。
做训练的模型，
所以包括，
我们后来知道的alpha go，
paum,
包括bot,
包括早期的early transformer,。
包括后来transformer，
都是用了这一套架构，
去做训练，
但那时候，
有一个比较大的问题，
就是那时候，
我们先有了硬件，
但是软件还没有跟上来，
对,
包括一直在VR，
V3，V4的时候，
就一直痛点，
就可能硬件上，
理论上，
我们的性能是不错，
对,
但是具体能部署多少，
第一产能跟不上来，
第二就是，
我们软件上，
那个鞋筒效应，
还没有产生，
所以一直在，
在做这样一个工作，
中间我们也提出了，
这个system,。
一个level,。
一个tpu pod,。
一个一个拓布的，
一个网络，
这也是奠定了，
现在tpu,
那么好的性能的，
一个基础，
然后在第四代的时候，
我们有针对，
recommendation,。
推荐和ranking的一个算法，
我们加入了，
一个spot score,。
稀疏式的计算单元，
这也很好的解决，
谷歌内部的，
一些推荐的，
一些workload,。
所以,
然后V5,
V6的话,
就是开始进入，
大模型时代了，
就进入，
下级bt时代，
所以我们那时候，
就会针对，
transformer,。
做了很多很多的优化，
然后一直到，
我们中间，
还推出了一个，
influence的版本,。
就是因为，
influence的市场,。
需求非常非常大，
直到现在的一期，
influence的版本,。
是从什么时候，
开始出来的？
v6吧,
我觉得，
v6,对,
我觉得那时候，
在tpu组里工作，
也挺有意思，
就是最开始那几年，
其实,
市场上没有那么大的，
需求,
相当于那时候，
没有大模型，
没有下级bt，
所以我们那时候，
工作还相对，
比较轻松一点，
因为只是针对，
自己家的workload，
所以感觉，
就是这样，
满足内部的需求，
就可以了，
对,
你是从哪一年，
开始在Google的？
我是从，
18年吧,
18年到,
24年,
那你基本上，
是完整的，
参与了，
好多代的，
tpu的开发，
对,
最开始我做的是，
另外一个project，
但我是从，
第五代的时候，
那核心的几代，
你基本上都有参与，
对,对,
我不能说是核心几代，
我只能说，
核心几代，
核心的肯定是，
第一代和第二代，
因为他们是电机者，
但后来，
我是可能经历了，
从,
模型快速迭代那个周期，
就是你可以，
一些想象的出，
就是最开始，
大家都在做训练，
但一下子，
哦，现在退市场，
一下子变那么火，
那我们，
要不要做另外一个，
版本的芯片，
然后,
project一直在，
是一个非常volatile，
变化非常非常快的，
一个状态下，
关于,
整个tpu,
他刚刚诞生的时候，
还有一些，
特别好玩的故事，
当时Jeff定，
他是谷歌的，
首席科学家嘛，
然后他其实，
是在一次，
整个内部的演示中，
去演示说，
深度学习网络，
他会,
怎么样去，
在语音识别上，
有一个突破性的进展，
就是,
2013年左右的时候，
然后那个时候，
大家其实就发现，
我们需要的是GPU，
而不是CPU，
然后后来呢，
就他们就开始，
在内部去demo，
这个事情，
就是Jonathan Rose,。
现在应该也是，
Groc的一个，
他应该是co-founder，
是吧,
现在已经是，
英伟达的VP，
对，现在是英伟达的VP，
因为英伟达收购了Groc，
对,
他当时就给，
内部demo的时候，
他就,
他就放了两页PPT，
第一页是，
就是,
这个GPU,
他真的是工作了，
这是好消息，
然后第二页就是，
这是一个坏消息，
我们付不起这个钱，
对,
就是他们当时是算了说，
成本,
对，成本，
就是说，
相互他们给谷歌，
发三分钟的语音的话，
那么当时谷歌的，
整个的，
数据中心的成本，
会,
就是增加一倍，
大概是数百亿美元，
是非常大的一个量，
这个其实也是他们，
就是,
开始去研究这个，
TPU的一个起点，
那,
接下来的故事，
好像就是到了，
整个一，
一五一六年，
就那个AlphaGo，
击败,
对，为其冠军，
你是使的时候，
这个时候，
其实谷歌，
已经在用TPU了，
而且据说，
在他们的这个，
AI算法里面，
是放了四张TPU进去的，
那个,
应该是第一代，
第二代对不对，
应该第二代，
或第三代吧，
第二代跟第三代，
对,
第一代是不做training，
那比如说，
刚刚你提到了，
其实可能，
整个大模型出来以后，
它是从这个，
第六代开始的，
而且前面，
它有一些是，
服务于谷歌的，
整个的搜索，
跟广告推荐的，
这些算法，
那第五代到第六代，
它相当于是一个，
巨大的方向上的转变，
对,
我觉得方向上，
转变更多，
就是,
呃,
相当于，
你可以把重心，
根据,
LM现实中的，
Wall Code,。
去做一些，
调配,
就其实，
理论上来讲，
就是high-level上来讲，
就是你把你的，
计算资源，
需要变得更大，
是,
对,
因为之前可能，
没有这样的case，
没有这样的wall case，
对,
软件团队，
是什么时候加入的，
你说XLA那边吗，
对,
他们从一开始，
就有这样的团队在，
嗯,
然后谁是这个，
tpu组的,
核心跟灵魂人物，
啊,
哈哈,
对,
我觉得，
相比,
现代我觉得，
软件团队的规模，
已经大超过，
硬件的规模，
对,
因为软件组，
确实,
它,
现在目前就，
生态中，
扮演一个，
非常重要的一个，
一个位置，
就是它，
不仅需要跟内部的人，
内部的团队，
的话,
以前会更加重一些，
嗯,
你就软件更加重一些，
那,
灵魂人物呢，
就比如说，
Jeff Ding,。
在推动这件事情，
他,
他肯定是在，
就是,
他早期推动，
早期推动，
后期呢，
后期的话，
后期我觉得，
可能,
就,
就我觉得，
现在肯定是，
Jeff Ding,。
包括D-Mine那边，
是一个，
深度的一个，
能够理解成一个大脑吧，
他决定的，
下一代tpu，
往哪个方向去发展，
其实落实是，
落到硬件组，
嗯,
就是,
落实是硬件组，
对，硬件组，
那我们刚刚其实，
提到了Johnson Rose,。
我们要不要讲一下Grogg，
因为,
因为大家其实，
也是把它收购了，
然后他在推理芯片端，
我记得他最开始出来的时候，
他的整个性能表现，
然后包括他说的那些方案，
在业界还是，
就是让很多人动心的，
对对对，
我觉得，
就我当初也，
也跟他们内部团队，
也聊过嘛，
然后,
他们被，
因为大家收购，
是裁准了，
每一个时代的红利，
裁准了，
每一个很好的时间点，
第一个时间点，
就是influence,。
然后第二时间点，
是asic,
第三时间点，
就是今年是agent的原点嘛，
想到有，
有很多智能体的爆发，
然后Grogg最好的一个，
应用case,
就是agent智能体，
因为agent智能体的话，
它对延迟的要求，
是非常非常高的，
如果说你的延迟，
做得很差的话，
你整个，
帮你去做，
这一个任务的，
一个链条，
从现场，
就是对于单用户来讲的话，
是一个非常痛苦的一件事情，
所以Grogg,。
就是很好地去解决，
或者说，
解决这样的一个问题，
Grogg的芯片，
因为Johnson Ross,。
最开始是tpu的compalating，
它是tpu compala那边的，
一个lacy founder,。
就相当于，
它是带了一套，
它,
非常成熟的tpu的，
那个compalaxla的一些经验，
去扣放了Grogg，
所以Grogg,。
你可以理解成，
它是一家compala的公司，
而不是一家芯片公司，
因为它的芯片，
更多是为它的，
软件compala服务的，
它的硬件，
可能比tpu更加的单一，
或者说，
没那么的智能一些，
它compala在某种程度上，
决定了一切，
它lpu里面，
每个时间点，
每个计算单元，
你们继续做哪些事情，
它可以精准到，
每一个cycle，
都是用compala去，
去确定好的一个，
非常确定性，
非常高的一个事情。
你刚刚提到，
他们精准的，
每一个就是，
时代的红利点，
第一轮是influence，
第二轮是asic，
第三轮是agent，
这三个时间点，
对芯片的要求，
有什么不一样吗？
influence的话,。
就是因为Grogg，
最开始，
他就做influence,。
他不做training，
他的软件和硬件的，
架构决定，
他做不了training，
第二个asic的话，
就相当于asic，
它的成本，
更加可控一些，
它是针对哪个方向的asic，
它是针对低延迟的asic，
主要是做低延迟，
所以现在agent，
我可以理解，
比如说，
现在我们用agent，
觉得延迟很低了，
它还是有硬件层面的提升的，
对，对，对，
这就是我刚才，
讨论的，
就是那个吞吐量的问题，
Grogg的,
他的tco,
比较好的原因，
就是你有很多，
海量的客户，
同时去用这样一个influence服务，
他的吞吐量就会很高，
但他不在乎，
他的尾部延迟，
尾部延迟，
指的就是，
你单用户用的话，
他可能会有时候会快点，
有时候会慢一点，
相信大家也都会有这样的用户体验，
但是Grogg,。
你一旦去用的话，
他就会非常非常快，
他的原理就是，
因为他，
第一是他的sram，
第二就是他是一个，
想到你一个人，
他占用了非常非常多的lpu的资源，
而不是跟很多人去共享，
他就这样一套逻辑，
agent跟asic的区别又是什么？
就我们再讲，
升到第三个逻辑，
agent当然跟asic。
没有很多的关联，
但agent的主要就是Grogg的一个，
非常适合Grogg服务的一个场景，
这是算是服务的一些客户，
适合Grogg服务的场景，
第一个是agent，
第二是real-time的一些voice，
然后还有一些高频的一些交易，
他对延迟的要求会更高一些，
所以现在Grogg他的客户，
主要是以那些客户为主，
比如说，
像你刚刚提到的高频交易商，
然后还有直播，
或者说跟大模型相关的这种时时的直播，
大家可以去google一下Grogg，
这一年他跟那些人，
那些,
那些厂家签了订单，
一个他跟那个中东的一个，
一个数据中心，
然后另外他跟IBM，
他相当于是一个
当地部署的一个计算集群，
他只针对本地人去用，
相当于在你家打了一个局域网的感觉，
一个私有的一个语音，
然后你用起来会非常非常新的，
非常非常高，
所以他卖的是什么，
就是你刚刚提到他是跟IBM签这种数据中心的合同，
我开始以为他是卖给Agent的，
就是他是卖芯片，
或者解决方案给这些Agent的创业公司的，
但是他现在看起来，
他是在往这个上游去卖，
具体细节不是非常清楚，
但我觉得他就是主打一个市场的差异化嘛，
就现在主流的市场都是做这种大模型的推理和训练，
可能就是针对一些小的规模部署的一些计算机群，
做这样的一个低延迟的一个性能优化。
你觉得未来在整个Agent的应用中，
就是推理芯片，
他是会是一个百花齐放的格局，
还是说他依然是以英伟达的GPU为主导的？
我觉得自从就是去年DeepSig出来之后，
大家一下子发现就是在推理端就是，
如果你成本打下来之后的话，
端策，然后本地的部署，
他的推理的需求是非常非常大的，
所以这样的话，
我觉得就是有很多不同layer的市场，
和不同layer的指标的需求，
当然Google和TPU肯定会占据最高层，
就是最大规模那些部署的，
包括育婴，包括那些大模型的推理，
然后中间和下面的一层的话，
我觉得会有更多的玩家，
更多的参与者进来，
然后这样的话，相当于Growk这块芯片，
其实它如果是一个非常大参数量的模型的话，
它其实成本就挺高的我觉得，
对，如果说是一个小规模部署的话，
它成本是可以控制的。
所以就是它未来就是整个芯片市场在推理端也会分层，
然后分应用场景？
对对对，可能最大量的需求还是这些大的巨头？
可能就是相当于你要是做startout创业公司的话，
你没办法说我要做下一家英伟达，
你基本上做不到，
因为它已经互称和实在太深太深，
你只能做一些伟端的一些客户。
很多人都在讨论TPU和GPU之间区别，
我数有数列，
但我觉得未来肯定是两者并存的，
包括现在所有很多大厂都在自理人自己家的芯片，
不管是推理还是训练，
我觉得你不能说GPU将来会一统江山和TPU会一统江山，
我觉得这个生态我觉得是一个非常健康的生态，
也有定制的环节，也有通用的环节，
也有通用场景，也有定制的场景，也有垂垒的场景，
所以我觉得将来的话是百花齐放的一个格局，
对，所以一旦产能各方面供应链都解决问题之后，
我觉得对用户来讲都是一件好事情，
我觉得对一下子把成本下来之后的话，
你能做的事情就无限的可能。
大家都需要有一个人能出来打破垄断。
对对对，我觉得目前TPU可能是一个很好的一个挑战者，
对对对，然后我们看一下它这个生态到底能布局到什么样的一个阶段吧，
如果它能把一个软件生态也像QDA一样打起来的话，
我觉得对QDA和GPU也是一件好事情，
我觉得需要同行的激励和偏测。
而且我觉得其实今天这个话题可能有很多方的人都会关注，
比如说从华尔街的视角，
他们会非常关注未来整个谷歌的TPU，
它能抢走这个因为大家多少的市场份额，
这绝对是他们就是来去计算估值的这样的一个非常重要的地。
对对对。
同时我觉得对很多的这种大模型厂商来说，
其实像不仅仅是我们刚刚提到的Anthorropica跟Mata，
我看像XAI甚至是OpenAI都表达出说，
未来可能会跟谷歌去进行TPU的合作。
我觉得从模型厂商这可能也是他们怎么样去提高自己的模型的能力，
同时降低自己数据中心的成本的一个非常重要的决策。
那我们再往下就是细到这个TPU它的整个的供应链环节，
包括我们刚刚说到的这个HBM包括夜冷，
然后包括数据中心它的布局有什么不同，
我觉得谷歌它的TPU的位置未来会影响到很多的产业链中的各个小的环节跟厂商。
对，所以还是很感谢Henry今天来我们的这样一期播客，
跟我们聊了很多的这个技术细节，
我觉得对大家这个做决策会有很多的参考价值。
对对对，那必须做一个声明啊，
就是今天我们所有的观点应该都是你的个人言论，不代表公司观点。
同时我们所有的这些言论也不构成任何的投资建议。
对对对，最后补充一点就是，
因为确实很多TPU的布局都是发展在高层，
就是他具体想把TPU得到成这样的一款产品，
我觉得相当于底下工程师是了解的比较少的，
所以我觉得我一直从我在Google的工作经历当中去播客，
同时聊天的过程当中去了解一些质言片语吧，
然后把它拼凑成一篇故事。
好的，谢谢Henry，谢谢。
谢谢，谢谢。
好，那谢谢Henry，
感谢大家收听我们这一期的播客。
如果大家对TPU有什么样的想法，
可以给我们写评论，写留言。
如果大家对我们的播客感兴趣，
可以通过苹果播客、Spotify还有小宇宙来关注我们。
如果大家喜欢我们这种视频播客的形式，
也可以在B站还有YouTube上搜索归股101播客关注我们。
我是红军，
感谢大家的收听。